- So, do you think that you
would have the survival skills
to survive in that kind of
environment, in real life?
- Oh my God, I mean, think
about the way I acted
with the spider.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- You know?
I don't know. (laughs)
- Who didn't, buddy?
- I'm gonna be honest, I don't know.
I mean, I think if I was gonna do it,
I don't think it would be a very,
fully functioning experience,
(Kelly laughing)
but I could probably get by,
you know?
- Yeah.
- Just like an ax and I can
make a really good fire.
My father was an Eagle Scout.
- Oh, yeah.
- So like,
he taught us to make good fires
when we were younger.
- I love
that your first thing.
- But that's about it.
- You thought of was an ax.
(everyone laughing)
I was like, whatever Paul Bunyan.
- I'm ready.
- I was like,
you're like ready.
- Yeah! When I went camping,
I brought my ax.
- Yeah.
- Yeah! I love an ax.
- I love it.
Okay, I love it.
(Chloe laughing)
I have like, look,
I'm not even gonna own
how weird I am, nevermind.
- Go ahead! (laughs)
- I'm really into like,
people used to make fun of me
and then a global pandemic happened.
- And then you're way too prepared.
- So, all my freeze dried
food wasn't so stupid.
- I have all of those.
- Was it?
(audience applauding)
Exactly.
- Yup. And the earthquakes.
- Just saying.
I know, earthquake.
- Yeah.
- I have friends that live here,
that are watching now upstairs,
and they don't have any things
in case of an earthquake.
- I have a to-go emergency box
in every room. (laughs)
- BOB, yeah.
It's a bug out bag, whatever.
- We're ready.
- Anyway, I'm crazy.